non-minimalists
we can't impose tranquility on the world
around us
so how do we adjust our internal
settings
to maintain inner tranquility i
the reason i like this question is
because
it's very honest and it exposes the
truth here about
tranquility so here is i'm going to give
you a pithy answer actually i have three
pithy answers for you here
but my first one is imposed peace always
leads to
conflict and that's the thing that we
often try to do especially in a
relationship with
others is i i'm going to force you to be
peaceful yeah i'm going to force
anything on onto you persuade you coerce
you that does not
work in fact it accomplishes the
opposite right
yeah if i'm tie you down and say be
peaceful
that's like me telling you to be in the
moment yeah
it sounds good i guess
maybe but living in the moment isn't
good or bad anyway it simply
is and we either are living in the
moment or we
are living for the future or the past
which is where most of us spend our
time living and so
you're talking about imposing
tranquility yes an imposed piece always
leads
to conflict so how do we adjust our
internal settings to maintain
inner tranquility well i will say this
here's my other
pithy answer for you all conflict arises
from
within there is no such thing as
external conflict
it may feel that way someone does
something
to you but they do something to you only
in so far as you allow that thing to be
done to you the insult or whatever in
fact i wanted to read a
an excerpt from direct truth it's kapil
gupta's book
and i thought this was a perfect answer
to this question for marianne
and it this chapter is titled
why do i get angry when i am insulted
hmm do you get angry when you're
insulted if someone says something snide
to you on social media
sometimes someone gets a defensive more
than insulted yeah
yeah and so well maybe not externally
defensive but i start to feel
defensive so when someone insults you do
you get defensive
and you would say yes to that right yeah
i don't know if i like voice my
defensiveness i try not to
but the visceral feeling is definitely
like a defense it's an
internal feeling too right it doesn't
exist in the real world it's
simply something that has arisen within
you right yeah so this
is this chapter in this book in fact
this entire book which i read in a
single sitting and then re-read it the
next day
a phenomenal book we'll put a link to it
in the show notes called direct truth
by kapil gupta and the
it's written as a q a right so it's
question
answer question answer right like it's a
it's like a student and a master
sort of having a conversation together
right and so i'll start with the
question and then i'll use a slightly
different voice for the answer
why do i get angry when i'm insulted
because you entertain the rarity of the
insult
how so how not so if someone calls me
stupid it does not mean that i'm stupid
nor does it mean that you are not but
i don't believe myself to be stupid then
anger would not arise within you
anger arises within me because they
unjustly accuse me of being stupid
i see you don't agree i understand that
you would like me to agree
i would like to know i've already
answered you but my answer was not to
your liking
but i i don't think of myself as stupid
i understand you don't believe me
i do not need your assistance in seeing
the truth
do you believe me that i think do you
believe that i think i am stupid
this question does not interest me
then how are you able to answer my
question
i have already answered it there's a
parenthesis here
this woman walked away in anger then
returned two weeks later
oh this is a legit conversation yeah one
of his uh clients oh well yeah
would you like me to tell you why i've
returned
if you wish i realized something
i was getting angry about you not
believing me when i said i didn't think
i was stupid
the fact that this made me angry
ironically illustrated the very point
that you were trying to make am i
correct
am i correct yes i apologize for my
foolishness
i am now ready to hear your answer
[Music]
i have already given you my answer which
is to say that
if i become angry at being called stupid
i believe myself to be
stupid i wonder if you might expand upon
this for me
if someone calls you a bird would you
become angry
no why not because
being called a bird is not an insult
very well
if someone were to call you a bird that
was too stupid to flap its wings
would this make you angry no
why not because it isn't true at all
yet when you are called stupid it makes
you angry
because something within you entertains
the possibility
that you might in fact be stupid
then something else within you grows
irritated by the idea
that you might be this internal conflict
manifests itself
as anger i see so
if not a single iota of a belief about
being stupid existed within me
that anger would not arise that is
correct
um that's good man there's like
it's funny because the and i don't know
if that's in
what you just read but there is
the truth that when someone calls you
stupid
and you start to get to and i start to
get defensive i'll put it on me someone
calls me stupid
i start to get defensive it's for for me
it's one or two reasons it's
either a piece of me thinks that maybe i
am stupid
um and then for some reason there's
another piece of me
that feels misunderstood yes
and that i'm doing something to make
people
think that i'm stupid right which is
which are both
in the ego but it's interesting how
sometimes the defense mechanism comes up
out of fear
of people believing something that isn't
true
right it's the the bird analogy there
right right like why do people think i'm
a bird
yeah if they're not bird said ryan and i
would insult you too by saying
your feathers are the ugliest color
you would just dismiss that right and
yet
and i misunderstand you i
clearly misunderstand you i mean it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of who
and what you are yeah but you're not
insulted by that at all
no although maybe like i take it to a
metaphorical sense what does he mean by
feathers
but yeah no i i understand what you're
saying yeah here's here's one more
pithy answer for you we put this in the
show notes if one has a deep enough
desire to eliminate conflict
they will remove anything that produces
that
conflict that was really the start of
this conversation ryan
even last week when we were talking
about the news and removing things it's
not about what you should do
i don't have a prescription in terms of
well here are the things that you should
subscribe to and not subscribe to it is
simply that
if there's something that is creating
conflict
then and you have a sincere desire
a deep desire to eliminate conflict
that's not to say you should have a
desire to by the way most people don't
have that desire at all in fact the
opposite is true have you been in a
relationship before ryan
where bickering was sort of the the
order of the day
yeah where it's how it was the way that
in which
you communicated with each other me too
and and i i've realized that in
parenting that was something that i was
doing as well i was bickering with my
daughter
as a po and i was creating unnecessary
conflict in her and in me
right also kapil would say all conflict
is self-conflict
i just sort of reworked that to say it
it rises from within
but but when i look at at that type of
conflict
that i'm creating i also realize that if
i don't want that conflict
then i should certainly re then it makes
sense for me to remove
anything that is producing the conflict
right that's minimalism right it started
with the stuff
it was creating this terrible conflict
in my life
but understanding that led to the action
it wasn't the other way around it wasn't
the
oh i picked up a book on decluttering
and i learned these seven steps and now
i've removed the conflict from my life
no it was about understanding that
conflict
then all the action sort of happens on
its own after that